[Music]
foreign
Interesting Man
Scotland
you're an Avenger
[Music]
you have a daughter
but you've lost a lot of time
like me
love each other with that
how are you
I'm the man who can give you the one
thing you want
what's that
time
you're right existence
and shatter timelines
you cannot trust him I don't care who
this guy is I just lost so much
[Music]
he can give us a second chance
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Captain Torrance how can I help you
fugitive extradition Boise dangerous
what did he do homicide 15 years ago I
don't want to scare the rest of the
passengers I'm afraid you're stuck with
this captain
[Music]
your captain speaking the seatbelt
science have been turned on
engine
it's run by separatists and militias
the right passengers my responsibility
I'm gonna need your help I'm gonna need
this
why'd they lock you up no one cares what
really happens
we're getting off this island
no need to worry folks these planes are
pretty much indestructible
18th
thank you
foreign
this is our chance to control the truth
the concepts of right and wrong for
everyone for centuries to come
you're fighting to save an ideal that
doesn't exist
never did
you need to pick a side
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Commander Mills my ship was hit by an
undocumented asteroid
[Music]
transporting 35 passengers
on a long-range exploratory mission
all right
send help
[Music]
we've crash landed on an Uncharted
Celestial body
[Music]
I've located One Survivor
a giant
foreign
there's something alien out there
foreign
you and I are gonna get home oh finally
ready
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
there is a Darkness coming
okay
it was all a dream
whoever I'm not driving
[Applause]
away
and if you don't know
of all the threats
from both your past
and future
never faced anything like this
let them come
and if you don't know
[Music]
saying goodbyes
saying hello
you think your wife can hear you
no
iBall
Maybe I'm Wrong
you're going to die
maybe not goodbye to you my trust
a new day is Dawning
new ideas no wounds no management we've
known each other since we
who is this
challenge him to single combat win a
lose it's a way out
I don't sit at the table your family
does please pray for me
I was the black sheep of the fan
man has to look his best when it's time
to get married
or buried
I'm going to need a gun goodbye my
friend
[Music]
if you win
the table will honor its word
we'll have your freedom
under the old laws only one can survive
failure to meet at sunrise
will result in execution
Last Words Winston
I want you to find your peace
only comes after good life
you and I left a good life behind a long
time ago my friend
[Music]
I'm Ria Khan I am going to be a stunt
woman
my sister Lena is the only person who
believes in me want to help me with the
vid for my Channel please
he helped me with all my training you
are going to be such a great stalker
that was Doppler but lately she's been
seeing this guy who I think is a bit of
a smarmy wanker
you know it's a truck oh my God we are
chill out now I'm not being dramatic
but these people are evil
I found something
I cut my eye on you they are not taking
her away without a fight
I will strike down you or anyone else
who tries to get in my way
how about the bikini area
Let's Dance
we need to get Lena
[Music]
how Mischief is a foot
Nina's not going anywhere you little
[ __ ]
root
mom what are you doing now
[Music]
nothing changes
we are going to show Rina who these
people really are
never
mind y'all calling me crazy
did you see my kick of course I bloodied
it it was magical
I'm pretty sure I drew blood
we were gone
for quite a while
but no matter what happens next
the Galaxy still needs its Guardians
we come in
come on Drax seriously dude
don't forget
where we came from
been running
our whole lives
I'm done running
[Applause]
[Applause]
we'll all fly away together
one man
to the forever
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
loves now you're just making it sad
[Music]
the great Doom is coming
[Music]
sins of the father are heaped upon the
sun
you have no clue the power of this book
possesses
I know those who seek it mean to do the
city harm
before it can be truly saved Gotham
must be burned to the ground
Talking Dead folks reptile plagues it's
not natural
it's a cult that has long ties to Gotham
Spirit we come to us now I can't pretend
to know exactly what I'm about to face
but I do know
that I must stop
its purpose and honor the damnation
before it
Mercy
what did this what's happening to you
what needs to happen
whose way must die
[Music]
hello Bruce you're happy
[Music]
[Music]
I spent the last seven years of my life
living out my wildest dreams
Bianca
Rocky
my dad
was built on their shoulders
hey my man can I help you let me get all
the grab nice not an autographs but get
off my car you don't remember me huh
[Music]
Damien
how long were you locked up 18 Years bro
just got out last week
I know I've been away a long time but
got myself in shape I still got gas in
the tank come by the gym
thank you
[Music]
carers what happened with you too oh you
can tell you he was like brothers
I was the best though but I never got a
chance to prove that that's cute
I know what you doing Donnie you don't
always do nothing
Damien's fighting the world he's trying
to hurt people I bounce for you you
think you mad trying to spending half
your life in the cell
why did somebody else live your life
I'm coming for everything you
threatening me
something is going on with you I mean it
was like family
[Music]
are we past talking then maybe you just
have to find out
I recognize mine I know that they needed
me automatic stress watching manifest
got my only fear I ain't scared of death
did you hear me yet
guilt
let go of whatever was and walk into
what is
[Music]
in days of Legend gods
walk the earth
foreign
what have I told you
Cena had returned in human form
and you are destined to become one of
her Guardian Knights
I'd say your therapist is more this
paycheck
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I can hear you being quiet mom
I am
hope I didn't ice your game man
no one my age says those words in that
order
it's just
see my little man not be my little boy
all the time
for years I've been taking care of this
little boy
making sure he is loved
that he feels like he belongs wherever
he wants to be
he wants to go out into the world and do
great big things
not bad kid
and what I worry about most I love you
moms
they won't look out for you like us
want to get out of here
wherever you go from here you have to
have to promise to take care of that
little boy for me
make sure he never forgets where he came
from and
he never doubts that he's loved
and he never lets anyone
tell him that he doesn't belong there
you gotta promise miles
I promise
[Music]
we are supposed to be the good guys we
are
[Music]
I miss the desert
I miss the sea
and I miss waking up every morning
wondering what wonderful Adventure the
new day will bring to us
those days have come and gone Perhaps
Perhaps not
[Music]
I don't believe in magic
seen things
things I can't explain
and I've come to believe it's not so
much what you believe
it's how hard you believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
who is this man I'm her Godfather
related
get back
the strands in your eyes they color them
one I've been looking forward to this
moment ever since baby Tommy was cut out
of my abdomen cheers everybody
[Music]
it's time
where is the pattern of the pride
Robert Robert they're calling you thanks
a lot Carol
here's the plan we're gonna head to the
next Island for help on my counts ten
nine why are you counting from ten but
is this a rocket launch you can find on
four this weekend hasn't exactly got a
plan Pirates chasing you wasn't on your
vision board you're the only thing on my
mission part
is that blood
[Music]
you okay yeah just you know I looked
over there and I saw the blood and you
know I think I saw some brain was that
brain stuff well you know what maybe we
should let's just step away
[Music]
here's the thing we're a team of Thieves
then when you do this
you're bound to make enemies
sometimes those enemies come looking for
Revenge
foreign
person steal the wrong thing
the greatest evil the world has ever
known
but we're gonna fix it so how do we pull
that off
uh figure it out over a drink probably
best you need to give us a fighting
chance we're gonna need strength you got
this right I know you don't
I'm gonna
do this we also need courage
[Music]
and you
what is that again it's now there
is
evil here
I'm glad he's on our side
foreign
this one's dangerous
but whatever happens
we'll be ready
is it exactly that you bring to this I'm
a planner I make plans you've already
made this plant so if the existing plan
fails I make a new plan so you make
plans that fail no he also plays the
loot not relevant
[Music]
Legion Academy if you want it you could
train here think of them as the Futures
Justice League
it is so great to meet you I'm monel
this is the rest of the academy trainees
different lies a ministering Justice and
preventing War
cousin is a problem she failed to
control her powers Brainiac
I am not going to let you hurt anyone
else with her abilities that makes her a
threat I don't like what you're implying
no idea where the rest of the Legion is
I've seen the dark circle come on we
don't have very much time it's up to us
so let's go be heroes
[Music]
Western power
[Music]
detective Knight what do you think makes
a good cop the good cop doesn't sleep
well so everyone else can
awesome
most cops are good
cops are our enemies you said he wanted
a real way to make change this is our
chance
kiss the ground
do you guys think the world would be a
better place without you in it
ain't got your answer right here
coming so a uniform badge gun
the city's tearing itself apart
ready
the world needs Heroes
[Music]
because they bring a tank called me
when you look outside do you see the
American dream
let's go
[Music]